joining us in the studio is the minister
of state for middle east and north
africa james cleveland mr cleverley
thank you so much for joining us on the
program this morning first of all we're
going to be hearing later on today just
how much it's going to cost people to
heat their homes one in four homes could
go into fuel poverty what are you going
to do about it well the
the government is very very well aware
we're all very very well aware of the
impact
on people's lives of the increase in
energy prices
that's why we've already put in a number
of targeted packages to support people
specifically about
um heating their homes and also things
like the
universal credit taper rate which gives
working families about
working people about a thousand pounds
extra the increase in the living wage
will again giving work people about a
thousand pounds extra a year um and the
chancellor has been looking at this and
we'll make announcements about what else
we could do to support because we are
very very we are acutely aware of how
difficult this will be for some families
and we're putting things in place to
help mitigate that is he also looking at
a windfall tax
well i don't want to preempt the
announcement that's going to be uh
coming soon from him so you will you'll
be seeing we will all be seeing what
additional measures we're putting place
on top of both the general and targeted
support that we've already outlined
because of course the prime minister has
said no to windfall tax and previously
the chancellor said no to a windfall tax
and everybody that i've been talking to
this morning has said unless there's a
windfall tax where you can get billions
of pounds from these energy companies
who make billions of pounds profit uh
then as i said one in four people are
going to be in fuel poverty well
there are often you'll always get people
who are very wedded to one particular
solution to a difficult situation but
the chancellor will be setting out
how we are going to support people who
are struggling uh to pay the bills as i
say
keeping people employed making sure
they've got money coming into their
pockets through their pay packets making
sure that as i say with things like the
universal credit taper and the uh and
the increase in the living wage we're
making sure people can
earn more to help offset that but as i
say we're also having in parallel to
that targeted measures to support people
with their energy bills that be enough
well for for some people they're always
still going to struggle we're very very
conscious of that but we really hope as
i say the combination of both general
financial support keeping people in work
making sure that work pays supporting
the people on lowest incomes and the
very targeted measures specifically
about
energy costs we'll we'll make sure that
the uh we hope the majority of people
who are concerned about the fuel bills
get support do you think for one second
that people like you and i who have
never had to worry about heating our
homes
and keeping warm have any comprehension
of how people who have to think about
either feeding the kids or turn the
electricity off
well
i can't comprehend it i have no
comprehension of that decision that
people have to make
so i've always been a lucky situation
that even the times in my life when i've
had money difficulties i've i've had you
know friends and family that have been
able to help so
i've never been in in really acute
poverty and
and you know i'm not going to pretend i
have but the point is in government in
politics you are
almost always having to derive policy
for people in circumstances different to
your own that's that's how government
works so we absolutely listen to both
the individuals and campaigners around
poverty that's why we're so passionate
about things like the leveling up agenda
to make sure that wherever you are in
the country you have the opportunity to
get a good job get a better job to get
more money
if you're out of work as i say getting a
job is is one of the best ways that you
can alleviate poverty and if you're in
work but on low pay
having things like the universal credit
taper rate having the uh the living wage
uh increase these things will help and
where they aren't quite getting there
that's where the targeted support comes
in okay oh well as i said i've just
underlined again one in four families
fuel poverty um what are the russians up
to buzzing our airspace
i i i can't i can't work out what russia
hopes to achieve
by this series of quite provocative or
indeed very provocative actions we
we we need them to understand that they
can be
an important significant player on the
world stage without this
the kind of military
aggression that we're seeing or this
military posturing that we're seeing
what happened can you underline that uh
so i don't i i don't have all the
details at the moment i don't want to
as you can imagine with something as
sensitive as this i don't want to
speculate or make it basically those
pictures are not relating to what we're
talking about just at the moment because
it was four aircraft russian aircraft
that was buzzing our airspace and the
raf had to go up and see them off
yeah and look this is not the first time
something like this has happened
and we have made it absolutely clear
that whether it is our own airspace
whether it is the territorial integrity
of our nato allies we stand shouldered
shoulder and indeed with the aggressive
posture that nato are putting towards
ukraine we have also said that we
absolutely support ukraine's right to be
a sovereign independent nation
we have provided
support over a number of years through
operation orbital which is training of
the ukrainian military and more recently
we've supported them with defensive
military equipment and we're making it
very clear foreign secretary uh did
earlier this week making it very very
clear that if russia
were
to further encroach on um ukrainian
territory that it would be a huge
strategic mistake and it would cost them
because of the sanctions regime that
we're putting the prime minister said it
would be a tragic miscalculation in what
way
well we're making it very very clear
that um russian individuals russian
entities would feel the pinch through
the sanctions regime
um and
and of course the other point is that as
we've seen images from the from ukraine
ukrainians are not just going to roll
over and take this
um and our fear is that would be it
would be protracted it would be bloody
it would obviously hurt ukraine but also
very much hurt russia all of this can be
avoided if russia de-escalate and move
those troops away from the border the
prime minister was given the opportunity
yesterday to apologize for his comments
that he'd made about linking uh the
leader of the opposition to jimmy savile
um the leader of the house made it very
clear that speaker of the house made it
very clear that he was not at all happy
why didn't he take the opportunity to
just apologize well the the prime
minister's made it clear that
the comments he made was in response to
um the leader of the opposition saying
leaders need to take responsibility for
the organizations they lead and that's
completely right but but kiyostama
himself
apologized for the organization that he
led in relation to the non-prosecution
of of jimmy savile and the prime
minister was highlighting that point all
these things are factually accurate um
as i say kirsten apologize for the
failings of the cps under his
leadership now um
just just to be clear that so kirsten
apologized for what happened when he was
at when he was dpp yeah
the prime minister is having parties
that he's hosting in downing street and
he won't apologize for that no the prime
minister has
apologized for what went on he has he
has said that he is going to take
parties
no but that's the point is the the prime
minister has apologized he's not saying
the work parties no the prime minister
has apologized for what happened you
know and yeah this is my question yes it
was
no i said apology has not apologized for
parties that went on at number 10. he
has apologized for um for what happened
he has apologized in response to the uh
things that have been highlighted from
uh sue gray's report and he has said
that he is going to take action to
address those things that's exactly the
right response when there are when the
report comes out there's critical
of an institution or events that is the
right response and that's exactly what
the prime minister has said he's going
to do that number 10 in his flat it
would appear and yet he won't apologize
well hang on you're making assertions
that uh that that um uh not referenced
in the su grey report if you know
something that i don't let me know but
from what the sue grey reporter said the
prime minister has accepted fully
the recommendations she's made he's
already starting to take action and he
has apologized for what's happened there
was an event in the downing street flat
that has been passed on to the police uh
where they sang abba songs
including the winner takes it all after
um dominic cummings left uh there are
photographs of the prime minister in the
flood on his way up to the flat not
necessarily in the flood because i
haven't seen those on his way up to the
flat so he was hosting parties at number
10 and he won't apologize and yet um he
uh slanders uh
the leader of the opposition uh and
suggested that he was involved in uh
crimes uh carried out by jimmy savile in
that he had to apologize because he was
the head of the department well you're
making a whole load of assertions that
are just not bad
okay well we're going to disagree on
that the point is
um
kirsten has apologized for the conduct
of the cps
during his tenure as leader right to do
so he said that he will make uh sorry at
the time he said that they will learn
from the mistakes that happen and make
changes and improvements right to do so
the prime minister has absolutely done
the same thing with regards to the
response to the sugar report the
assertions that you're making i mean i
can only judge on what is in the public
domain the sue uh the sue grey uh update
was was published in its entirety um and
i'm basing my comments on what is in
that report if you know other stuff
that's absolutely fine i've not seen
those reports i've not seen those
photographs so i'm only going to comment
on the stuff that i have okay let me
talk to you about what's happening in
afghanistan um alex crawford is there
she the most harrowing stuff that
she has been sharing with our viewers
she accepted i can't put it on my
programme until after nine o'clock this
morning because it's just so harrowing
let me just give you a little taste
here actually they're having to cram
babies onto beds in the main provincial
hospital it's standing room only here
a measles outbreak is ripping through
them in the tiny with already poor
immunity measles can be a death sentence
the insecurities meant vaccines haven't
been given
and many of those babies subsequently
died i know that you're a parent too
what should we be doing to help the
people of afghanistan
well the situation in afghanistan is is
absolutely
horrific and
uh and this is a reflection of the
situation there i mean the government
has already committed uh 280 million
pounds in direct additional humanitarian
support to afghanistan clearly the
the challenging situation is how we
interact with the taliban
um and we
want to make sure that whatever support
we give to the afghan people gets to the
afghan people people like that
and isn't well and this is the challenge
we need to make sure that it isn't
diverted by the taliban or others and
and there are other organizations um who
are focused on terror and atrocities
based in afghanistan we want to make
sure that they don't benefit from money
that that people like that need um so we
are absolutely committed to continue our
support in afghanistan it is technically
incredibly difficult because of the um
of the actions of the taliban we will
continue to continue but the point is
okay it's it's it is it is not easy to
address it if there were a simple
solution obviously we would take
advantage of that simple solution but
it's it's not simple um and yeah we will
continue working
uh in whatever way we can to get support
to the people who need it and keep money
away from the people who would use it to
further terrorize not just afghans it's
worth giving them the aid even if some
of it is hived off by the taliban in
order for those babies to be so we are
giving aid but the simple truth is that
um it would be it would be
unconscionable
if we were
knowingly letting money be diverted to
people who would use that money to
terrorize exactly people like that and
others internationally um so so we are
being
careful with uh how we expend our money
but as i say we are we have um we've
already committed uh 280 million pounds
plus in additional humanitarian aid
uh we are delivering that uh in uh in a
way that gets it to the people that need
it
not to the people who'd use it for uh
for terrorism we are absolutely focused
we you know we we do have as the british
people we have a long-standing and very
understandable commitment to the afghan
people and we will we will make sure we
can do what we can